la halle était en travaux depuis
décembre et la ville pensait pouvoir
avancer par tranches sans évacuer les
lieux
mais mardi dernier en cours on a un
teint de hambourg où il met vraiment un
beau y comme c'est que c'est une bombe
ou quelque chose qu'on a mis comme ça
tout le monde un petit peu bonbon
s'affoler pour savoir et après ça va
vous casser le poteau l'un des poteaux
qui soutient la structure s'est
affaissée brutalement d'une quinzaine de
centimètres sur ses poteaux métalliques
la rouille a fait son oeuvre est partout
ils menacent de lâcher risquant de faire
chuter la mezzanine et ses restaurants
ou de briser les nombreuses surfaces
vitrées présente en façade comme en
toiture ont été uniquement ya un risque
pour la sécurité des personnes qui se
relaient à l'intérieur et aux abords
immédiats du marché et moi je peux pas
prendre le risque qu'il y ait des
blessés
donc il faut absolument qu'on mette
d'abord les personnes en sécurité donc
on déplace le marché pendant la durée
des travaux qui prévues jusqu'en
décembre
depuis l'aube
c'est donc le branle bas de combat pour
les 55 marchands de la halle priés
d'évacuer entièrement marchandises et
équipements jusqu'à la fin des travaux
épices fruits et légumes les ménages
face à la cour perrinon et les produits
touristiques rejoignent le marché du
malecon son petit peu triste mais pour
notre sécurité nous étions obligés
d'évacuer nous pouvons pas rester dans
un marché où il ya un danger dessus moi
me moyen de lui en ont offert le gros
c'est difficile
nous avons passé il a fait quoi toi
porter à six mois il a fait quoi pour
toi la dépense par les professeurs lui
la ville vont ils voir les buts y aura
un impact sur nos trois sets sur disque
en aura qu'une table les places on va
diminuer l'étape c'est normal
pourquoi tout le monde est une place
mais ça va les choses s'annoncent
pourtant plus compliqué pour les six
restaurants du marché toujours en
attente de solutions pour déménager leur
table et leur cuisine
dès ce matin en revanche les vendeurs de
fruits et légumes ont commencé à
s'installer face au centre perrinon de
sérieuses aménagements ils seront
nécessaires pour le confort de tous sous
le soleil ou la pluie